SPEAKER: Let me show you how
Google can help you secure some
of your most sensitive data.
Most companies
today have a policy
around data minimization,
the goal being
to minimize the amount of data
that you collect and store
to only the data that's actually
needed to run your business.
But that's easy to do in words,
but hard to do in practice.
Data has a way of leaking
out all over the place.
So let's look at a
concrete example.
We have an enterprise
application
that a support agent might use
to chat with your end users.
And in the chat you can see
Neil is a support agent,
and he's asked Alice
for some information
to verify her account.
Well, Alice has way over-shared.
We just wanted the last
four of her social.
She gave us her full social,
her phone number, and a picture
of her social security card.
Now, obviously we want to
store this chat, right?
To see how our
conversations are going,
or how the agents are working.
But I can't store
that in a database.
I'm going to have
half my company now
knowing Alice's social
security number.
So how do we do that?
DLP makes it easy.
When he ends the chat, we
will use Data Loss Prevention
to identify and redact
sensitive information.
So now you'll see that we've--
[HOOT FROM AUDIENCE]
Yes.
[APPLAUSE]
We recognize over 40 different
types of sensitive info types.
In this case we've
identified Alice's name.
If he scrolls down
a little bit, you
can see we found her phone
number, her social security
number, we replaced all
those with red dots.
And even we went into the
picture of the social security
card, found the social security
number there, and redacted it.
Now this chat can be
used for analysis.
[APPLAUSE]
Now just to prove this is real,
Neil has a webcam over there,
and we're going to
try one more example.
I was in the green
room a while ago,
and I found this credit
card sitting there,
and it said Urs Holzle.
I'm just kidding, Neil
has a sample credit
card with a valid number,
but it's not Urs's card.
I trust DLP.
I don't trust 10,000 of you
with cell phone cameras.
So he's going to put the
credit card number on it,
he's going to hit the button,
we're going to use DLP,
and it will find and
redact the credit card.
[APPLAUSE]
Now this isn't just dumb OCR.
You'll notice it didn't
blot out the expiration
date or the name,
because we told
the API that the
only information we
wanted to eliminate was
credit card numbers.
So you can control
your definition
of PII, what matters to you.
So there you have it.
Identity [INAUDIBLE] proxy.
We made it super simple to
take a corporate application
and make it available
for end users,
without the hassle of complex
network configurations.
And with data loss
prevention, we
were able to help it make sure
that you minimize the amount
of data that you collect.
So that's one less headache
you have in terms of compliance
or regulatory or really
just running your business.